a man who won an Oscar for writing a
movie that he direct you is also in and
Slingblade monsters balls simple plan
Friday Night Lights obviously folks of
who watch this show will have seen that
and then there was Fargo on television
including right now Goliath season two
of the Amazon Prime original series is
available for streaming tomorrow the man
who won the Golden Globe for his role as
Billy McBride in Goliath here on the
show good to see you again Billy Bob
Thornton so let's get right into it
um the st. Louis Cardinals are your team
correct yes sir okay so now they are
seemingly locked in to a three team
battle right now in the National League
Central it seems they're gonna fight it
out with the Cubs and brewers all your
looks like and and so what it what it
just seems like every year they have
what it takes and it's either they're
gonna get it done in September to get
into October or not is that an accurate
portrayal yeah of your franchise do you
think Billy
I think everybody's team drives them
crazy at some point you know and I watch
every game and yell at the TV you know
the whole thing and you're yelling about
strategy yeah stuff like that it's like
you know what leave him in leave him in
one more inning I'm telling you if you
don't here come four runs next inning I
promise you and then when it happens
jumping up and down almost in triumph
just because all right you know I'm
gonna tried-and-true Cardinal fan I just
love the team and the reason is is
because I grew up in Arkansas and their
double-a club was in Little Rock the
Arkansas travelers so we saw a lot of
those guys come through there and would
you see come through there Keith
Hernandez you know I remember
specifically you know one guy that I
remembered actually seeing sure no and
but it was it was great
and I remember they had a thing called a
$5,000 hole and on the right-field line
on the on the wall there was a hole
there maybe that big around you know and
if one of the players hit the hit a home
run through that hole he got $5,000
which in the minor-league
that was money that's serious exactly
and I think somebody did it or has done
a couple times I never saw it done but
anyway so yeah always a Cardinal fan I'm
in an Indianapolis Colts fan and it's
been a rough few years now that that
that connection is Peyton Manning is
that the connection there or what was
the connection it was a Baltimore Colts
fan okay
I liked the Johnny Unitas days when I
was a kid and everybody was a Cowboys
fan in my area you know and and I was
too I loved the Cowboys but for some
reason maybe just to be different I
followed the Colts and then they snuck
out of town in the middle of the night
and I kept up with him in Indianapolis
but yeah I love Peyton Manning so much I
just think he's a just one of the
greatest not only athletes but just a
cool dude you know you got a chance to
meet him I've never met him no I sent me
a jersey and autographed jersey though
no kidding
yeah for what just out of the blue I
just asked for it I said you know so
what is your favorite what's your Billy
Bob Thornton here on the Rich Eisen show
what is your best sports memorabilia
that you have that you're most proud of
or something that you love oh it's I've
got a bunch of things that I love but
the one that I would have to say is the
coolest simply because it's not because
I was a baseball player so baseball
stuff means a lot to me one year a
girlfriend of mine said if you could
have anything for Christmas this year
what would it be and I said an
autographed baseball glove from Brooks
Robinson because Brooks was from
Arkansas you grew up in Little Rock
North Little Rock and I just loved him
you know when he played with the Orioles
and so I thought that's never gonna
happen
but if I could have anything that's what
it would be and she chased him down she
got all the publicists and everybody
else on the case and Christmas morning I
open it up and there was an autograph
book Brooks Robinson glove and it said
and of course you know the glove from
him that's the thing because she was
fielding you know and it said from a
huge fan Brooks Robinson I'm like Brooks
Robinson knows who I am I'm done this
this is this is all fine
but I speaking of Bruce Robison I have a
sports trivia question for you oh gosh
okay okay yes no everybody misses one
guy Baltimore Orioles I think was in 70
that had four 20-game winners who were
all four um okay you're gonna name three
of them for sure
okay Palmer okay
choir - okay I'm halfway home was was
Flanagan on the team that's prior to
that right well just also to let you
know a Billy I have an earpiece in my
ear
oh okay Jay diehard Baltimore fans
shooting the shots right who's slicing
up the shots right now oh gosh
who else is that nobody's saying
nobody's getting in my ear right now
okay McNally McNally there you go you
just got the three that everybody gets
when the fourth one is who's the fourth
one Pat Dobson I would never have gotten
that nobody ever does so you're a
baseball trivia guy basically well no no
you know Jeffrey Lyons
of course yeah Jeffrey Lyons right Yeah
right this cat knows everything he and
Bruce Dern no more sports trivia than
any body owner we've had Bruce turn on
on our on this show and the stories that
this guy tells unbelievable are
unbelievable and also though it's
interesting that you know we just had my
canes on in the last hour that the the
movie Black Sunday was not shot at his
Super Bowl but just a couple of Super
Bowls before the one that he played in
and Bruce Dern oh yeah was in that movie
I mean I mean that guy we had him on our
podcast - oh yeah he was unbelievable
he's somebody who's very excited about
sports gambling returning I believe
correct yes but you know the thing about
him it's like you have a lot of people
who know trivia from college sports or
pro sports or whatever but Bruce will
meet a guy I mean I'll just bring a name
out anybody let's say Franco Harris I
don't know I don't know
we're Franco Harris went to high school
but and this is not it but Bruce would
go yeah Franco Harris two blocks down
from the high school that Johnny Unitas
went to two blocks away and they didn't
know each other and five years later
they had a head-on collision with each
other it's unbelievable that he knows
where everybody went to high school and
I'm talking about people who were pole
vaulters I mean he knows stuff like that
it's like I I can't name a pole vaulter
no that's just like him by the way so
where Billy Bob I guess then before he
thought of breakout man did it ask did
you ever put on the Brooks Robinson Club
like literally put your hand oh I put it
on but boy do I protect it it's a I
finally put it in plexiglass because
it's you know the name might rub off you
know yeah you don't it boy that's a
that's a real dandy saying Maguire also
gave me a bat right after he broke it
you know right after he broke the the
Maris no no after he broke his bat oh he
grounded out to third but it was that
year okay it was that year and yeah he
grounded out to third yes the Dodgers
and he gave me the bat and his batting
glove which had dirt all over it and
everything so I've got that and yeah I
got some good stuff over the years
that's so funny he gave me a broken bat
you grounded out to third yeah
absolutely
we're back in 60 seconds we'll talk a
little bit more with Billy Bob Thornton
Goliath is available for streaming in
season two billy mcbride himself from
goliath
Billy Bob Thornton we come back in 60
seconds
so many choices for streaming TV shows
out there it's ridiculous but if you are
up for one you should choose Goliath on
Amazon Prime and not just because Billy
Bob Thornton you are sitting here my
wife and I have been binging season 1
we're excited for season 2 you are
awesome in it
David E Kelly creating a lawyer
character that you play that is
something that is good eats if you're a
an actor and it seems like you are
having a blast doing this still watching
it Billy absolutely I love playing this
character yeah it's the only thing that
I've come across the last few years that
I would do on a regular basis I know I
could play it from now on actually I
love it now I know because when you did
Fargo that was kind of a one-off because
that's the way that that series is set
up changing characters completely from
season to season even decades so this is
this the first TV show that you've done
like as a recurring character where it's
just based around somebody laying pretty
much I mean except for when I was first
coming up right you know you know I did
TV back then I remember doing an episode
of Matlock and Knotts land and stuff
like that I mean you noticed a few lines
were you in a scene with Andy Griffith
no I I actually wasn't I I was so
excited to do Matlock and then you get
there and you find out it's you know
your scene was like some other guy like
you seen with some guy named buddy or
whatever it's like hey nice to meet you
but and again Matlock those were back in
the days where those were the types of
shows about a lawyer oh yeah what you're
doing right now is completely far other
also far afield of what David E Kelly
has done with with lawyer characters as
well what what I mentioned earlier what
attracted you to this role I'd love to
give you the the floor once again for
the radio audience now that's here about
what why you decided to do this well
it's just you know something that I've I
read it and I knew it was right for me
and it's not that it's not that
different from what I think I would be
if I were a lawyer in LA I mean it's
just everything about it was right you
know hanging out in the dive bar JJ out
there
by the reach absolutely yeah you get
beat up quite a bit in the show yeah I
do yeah
I'm used to it though and so
interestingly enough and this one hit me
because I'm such a huge fan of the film
your character Billy McBride go play
somebody who's once had a huge amount of
success now down on his luck trying to
come back by beating a Goliath right and
the through line and all this is the
movie Hoosiers Ryan coached Normandale
oh and the speech that is given prior to
the game against you know the big huge
goliath feta Milan was taken on about
the David and Goliath the philistine etc
etc right that that spoke to me I'm
wondering if it spoke to you when you
read that in the script absolutely and
it came about it actually wasn't in the
script what was there was my backstory
that was given to me by one of the
producers who is that I'd gone to the
University of Indiana right and so once
I had that Hoosiers is one of my
favorite movies and my favorite sports
movie so I thought okay well I'm gonna
throw something in every now and then
about Hoosiers and there are a couple of
times when I'm actually watching
Hoosiers on my laptop in the series
rented and kind of like mouthing the
words along cuz and in real life I know
it too like every scene and and we were
talking about Stacey about how no matter
how many times you watch Hoosiers you're
always nervous you're always afraid
they're gonna lose and you know it's I
talk back to the movie still I probably
seen it 500 times let me to just over
and over I've seen that movie so this
was your idea let's get the movie
Hoosiers involved in in in the show yeah
the Hoosiers part was the Indiana part
right that's used it but use the the
film let's use the speech there's not a
week that goes by in my life Billy Billy
Bob that I'm serious here that there's
not a week that goes by where I don't
use some line from that film oh yeah as
a metaphor for what's happening in my
life yeah
the rims the floors still the same
height and that the you know the
baseline is still the same no to the
free-throw line
it's unreal how and then he turns to his
assistant there on the way out after the
players are out of earshot and he says
it is big it's big yeah it's amazing
so how many sports movies have you had
the opportunity to do I mean I know
obviously if you had Friday Night Lights
if there's that something bad news bears
obviously doing the the Buttermaker
right yeah other than that I mean mr.
Woodcock I play a PE teacher but uh but
you know I forgot about that one right
and the thing about it is this you know
sometimes Hollywood it can be
narrow-minded and once you do something
that's successful they want you to keep
doing it it again and so I got offered a
bunch of Coach roles everybody Night
Lights yeah I mean even or after mr.
Woodcock all of them but you just can't
keep doing them you know I mean it's
like I got offered a soccer coach I know
as much about nuclear physics as I do
about soccer I really do it's one of the
sports I mean I like Liverpool I follow
them only because my people are
originally from the area but I don't
know what they're doing I've only
recently gotten to where I can halfway
understand hockey because growing up
where I did
hockey was just didn't exist for us I
know and and I it took me years with
soccer and hockey a cycle they they call
somebody offsides there they all look
offsides
to me it's like what does that even mean
you know and but I do follow some other
sports that you know not all my buddies
do I'm a UCLA softball fan okay love
that team and follow them to the NCAA
World Series and all that kind of stuff
you know kind of lost out there in the
semi-finals but golf is something I
never watched until the last two or
three years and I started watching it
because I got fascinated with the LPGA I
mean
huh and I was like wow these gals can
play golf so you're gonna be watching
the US Open this weekend you're gonna
yeah watch it off and on you know it's
it's it fascinates me I'm terrible at it
I tried it a couple of times and I just
it's interesting because baseball
players usually it does translate to
golf in a way some baseball players I
was a pitcher well I mean I mean but you
know I I can drive okay it's the pudding
that I have yeah yeah that's the pudding
for generalizing I'm good at yeah I
can't put Billy Bob Thornton here on the
Rich Eisen show I'm keen you know
diehard sports fan that you are what did
you learn out of Friday Night Lights did
you learn something out of immersing
yourself and that scene in immersing
yourself on in the book and the film and
well I don't know I I grew up in a
Sports household my dad was a coach he
was a high school coach he coached
basketball but I I knew what it was like
to live in a household with a coach and
I guess them m-most I learned from that
movie was just about that specific team
in that situation you know with Gary
Gaines he was a real guy and I played
him and you know exactly how seriously
they take football down there in Odessa
and Midland you know that area I mean
Texas in general but Odessa I mean that
Stadium when we shot there it's like a
college Stadium you know I'm in my high
school Stadium we had bleachers on our
side mm-hm and then the visitors side
you know were like a few benches you
know it was just another world and this
place literally looked like the stadium
at the college I went to and they the
speech that you delivered that is been
made so famous in his recounted did you
Adlam any of that was that written for
you word for word did you pull on
anything some of it was written and I
asked Pete Berg the director I said
listen the literally the night before a
friend of mine screwed me over in a way
that I can't describe I was so
devastated by something a friend had
done to me in real life in real life and
is Peter said can I
kind of go off of this and just talk
about some other stuff and he said sure
whatever you want to do and all that
stuff about if at the end of the day you
can look that guy next to you on your
team in the eye and know that you did
everything you could you know all that
stuff was directly related to what
happened the night before and that made
the film no yeah damn straight it did
yeah so no that's usually the best stuff
in a movie anything that you comes
straight out of something organic you
know it's anything in Goliath like that
because you do a lot of crazy there's a
whole lot of stuff in it we need a whole
new show to do something like that
am i by the way my my Kourtney producer
got on my ear and told me during our
conversation what you're credited role
in that Matlock episode is do you
remember I played a guy worked at a pawn
shop I remember that you are a pawn shop
broker sir yeah no one can ever take
that credit away from they can't do it
they just can't I don't know who does do
you ever hear that I always wonder that
who are the people that try to take into
anything away from you like though I
don't take that away from I know
what's interesting about being an actor
when you're first coming up is you're
you scan through the casting papers and
stuff like that now and when you see who
you think you are I always thought that
was interesting you know and you would
see roles in there would say this
terribly obese guy with one eye and you
know pathetic creature whatever and then
the guy who goes that's me you know and
they show up for the audition you know
what I mean it was always interesting so
I I don't remember what I thought of
myself
not much but but that's what you had to
do you'd have to look at lucked in the
drama log paper and all this kind of
stuff for what you were right for well
I'll tell you what man you were right
for this role
Billy McBride in Goliath I'm loving it I
really really am looking forward to
season 2 big time and Morris Chestnut is
on tomorrow's show to talk about it oh
nice yeah really nice guy Morris I like
him I'll tell you what my there's a
credit on my filmography Billy Bob where
I'm playing I played Rich Eisen in like
Mike nice yes
excellent no one can ever take that away
from you know what nobody can do it like
you can no and ivory every every so
often I go to my mailbox I get an
envelope from a Screen Actors Guild
anywhere between 15 to 80 cents
absolutely that's the cheque yeah baby
yeah oh yeah less than the stamp at the
gas it cost to go put it in the back are
you still getting residuals from that
not luck just once in a blue moon
absolutely yes oh yeah yes indeed
great to see you great to see you Billy
Bob Thornton here on the Rich Eisen show
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience